التقت العربيه الاقباط المصريين الذين تم
اطلاق سراحهم بعد خطفهم على يد مجهولين في
الغرب الليبي حيث تمكن مراسل العربيه من
الوصول الى المخطوفين داخل مدينه الزاويه
بعد تدخل حكماء وشيوخ المنطقه الغربيه
ورئيس لجنه مكافحه الهجره في مجلس النواب
علي ابو زريبه بالتعاوني مع جهاز دعم
الاستقرار في المنطقه الغربيه بقياده حسن
ابو زريبه
نحن راكبين الطيران من يوم 3/2
طيران برج العرب بني غازي
وصلنا عدينا على طرابلس
وصلنا طرابلس يوم 4 يوم
4/2 ركبنا عربيه عدينا بها على البوابات
شدينا من بوابه مشينه لقدام بعد كده عصابه
حجزتنا عنديها قعدنا حوالي 15 يوم مشدودين
طلبوا علينا في خلونا بعد اربع ايام
نتكلموا في التليفون كلمنا اهاليني طالبين
علينا فديه 15,000 دينار على الواحد
طبعا قلنا له الفلوس دي هلبه احنا ما
نقدروش يعني نوفر الفلوس دي او نجمعوها
لازم 15 الف
[موسيقى]
نخدم بايديني
فيطلبوا منا احنا فلوس
أرمونا في سيون لاكل شرب
لحياه قاسيه الم
سعينا كل المجهودات وكل الوسائل مع جميع
اعضاء الناس اللي هم لهم مكانه في الزاويه
وغيرها حتى استطعنا ان نخرج هؤلاء الناس
الابرياء اخواننا المصريين لتربطنا معهم
سيره الجوار حاولنا ان احنا نسددوا لهؤلاء
الناس في فلوس اللي طلبوهم وطلعناهم بكل
صدق وامانه وهم معنا يعني يعني في حريه
كامله وهم الان في امن في امان وفي مكانهم
وفي بيتهم هنا في منطقه ابو سره من زاويه